bonjour maroni comment ça va aller
alors aujourd'hui je t'amène chez madame
le bon une agricultrice qui a bénéficié
de l'aide du département pour son label
bio
[Musique]
c'est vous aussi l'accompagnement à
l'aide du département pour rembourser
votre label bio vous intéresse alors
suivez moi si tu sais que cela se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me trouve aujourd'hui au tampon sur
l'exploitation de madame le bon elle est
agricultrice et a obtenu depuis
maintenant quatre ans son label bio
chaque année madame le bon doit payer le
maintien de sa certification et le
département apporte son soutien pour la
financer
bonjour madame le bon et merci de nous
accueillir dans votre ferme aujourd'hui
alors comment avez vous obtenu le label
bio je suis retourné un petit peu vers
le département et même dans le
groupement d'agriculteurs je suis pour
me faire aider parce que du coup je
voulais vraiment faire reconnaître ma
culture
la parcelle à doit être en friche on va
contrôler pas mal de choses on utilise
plus de produits
non autorisés en agriculture biologique
alors qu'est-ce que vous produisez ici
et surtout pourquoi produire bio alors
déjà pour manger sainement ça c'est la
première chose qui m'est venue donc on a
fait de la grume sur pratiquement la
totalité des parcelles qu'on a donc on
est à huit mille mètres carrés de dagris
bio certifiés bio et on fait aussi après
dessous un petit peu de maraîchage pour
la table et pour la ferme aussi bien sûr
merci madame le bon je vous en prie
comme madame le bon et beaucoup d'autres
agriculteurs le département accompagne
ces derniers en quête d'une
certification bio en effet chaque année
les producteurs doivent payer leur
certification et c'est à ce niveau que
le département intervient une aide très
appréciée permettant ainsi aux
agriculteurs de soulager leurs dépenses
alors dites nous comment faire pour
bénéficier de cet accompagnement au
niveau de la cellule d'accompagnement
des agriculteurs
on nous menons un travail de proximité
en informant les agriculteurs sur ce
dispositif est également leur proposant
une aide au remplissage des dossiers si
besoin bien entendu nos collègues du
service instruction prennent ensuite le
relais pour le traitement de ces
dossiers depuis plusieurs années
maintenant le département accompagne les
agriculteurs dans leurs démarches
d'obtention du label bio notamment par
la mise en place d'une aide annuelle au
remboursement des frais de certification
le montant de cette aide est plafonné à
600 euros par an et qui peut bénéficier
de ce club cette aide est accessible aux
agriculteurs à titre principal et
secondaire ainsi qu'au groupement
d'agriculteurs sur présentation des
pièces justificatives indispensables à
la constitution des dossiers alors
justement comment faire pour s'inscrire
et bénéficier de cette aide le
formulaire de demande peut être
téléchargé sur le site internet du
département le demandeur peut également
se rapprocher de la cellule
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs qui
veut lui transmettra merci madame morel
je reviens si alexandre
chaque année comme madame le bond de
nombreux agriculteurs bénéficient du
soutien financier sur la certification
bio ils sont suivis régulièrement par
les agents de la direction de
l'agriculture
une manière de s'inscrire durablement
dans une agriculture de meilleure
qualité
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide pour
l'obtention de la certification bio
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revend cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents rendez
vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux
quant à moi je vous retrouve très vite
pour un nouvel épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous emmène chez
madame nous le breton qui a pénétré de
l'agrément du département pour devenir
accueillant familial une reconnaissance
obligatoire pour pouvoir accueillir à
son domicile des personnes en situation
de handicap aux débats stands âgé de 60
ans nous fêtons pas aucune peuvent plus
vivre seul et qui privilégie un cadre de
vie familiale